prenons une antenne souhaitais les
oscars ont couronné le film no madeleine
mais derrière les sourires il y ait une
certaine angoisse car à cause de la
pandémie
partout sur la planète la sortie de
plusieurs films ont été compromises au
québec
l'arrivée en salles du film souterrain
étaient prévus en octobre mais elle
était repoussé deux fois c'est sûr fêté
la promo qui doit se faire avant une
sortie film ya des stratégies qui sont
qui sont mises en place pour pour avoir
le plus de monde en salle alors toutes
ses efforts leçon tombe à l'eau en fait
tous ces efforts le son ont été mis pour
rien deux fois dans notre corps en
attendant une sortie en salle
souterraine représentait mercredi pour
donner le coup d'envoi des rendez-vous
québec cinéma
l'équipe du film les vieux deux hommes
travaillent à la promotion mais sans
savoir s'il se retire comme prévu en mai
ni de vue comme les biens cette question
doit à tous les jours est-ce qu'on
décale est-ce qu'on retard mais ça fait
déjà un an qu'on regarde mon le
couvre-feu est un peu absurde par contre
dire que
je pense qu'ils peuvent aller jusqu'à
9000 6 7 à 8 ans moi je veux dire non je
dire non mais en même temps je touche à
l'absurde le film le club england et la
déesse des mouches à feu qui sont sorti
brièvement sur les écrans ont été
retirés à cause du contexte défavorable
quand tu te va mais le film français les
choses qu'on dit les choses qu'on fait
c'est toujours la fiche pour une
deuxième semaine au québec et au nouveau
brunswick
c'est très dur parce que les salles sont
sont toujours fermés ici chez nous que
beaucoup de films attendent donc c'est
dur mais on a de l'espoir et on a de
surcroît l'espoir que tous ces temps ci
on a été enfermé vont provoquer on va
dire une vague importante de désir pour
le pour le cinéma
si certaines salles restait fermée au
québec celles qui sont encore ouvertes
10 tiré leur épingle du jeu au niveau de
la programmation avec les films
indépendants qu'on a les films européens
des fins québécois on est capable de
trouver une programmation intéressante
pour tout de suite
en ces temps incertains l'industrie
cinématographique se croisent les doigts
pour que le couvre feu repasse
rapidement à 21h30 ce qui permettrait
d'ajouter une séance de début de soirée
et changerait considérablement la donne
sinet bien alexandre chartier radio
canada montréal